[Музика]
добре, хлопці, я радий бачити вас сьогодні
знову
[Музика]
сьогодні ми поговоримо про
Олімпійські ігри, і це буде
урок читання добре, я хочу, щоб ви прочитали сакс
разом зі мною ви побачите слова,
виділені жирним шрифтом, будь ласка, зверніть
на них свою увагу, вони знадобляться після
прочитання добре,
давайте зарядимося читанням Олімпійських
ігор Олімпійські ігри вперше були проведені в
Греції між 776 р. до н.е. і 393 р. н.е.
була серія  змагань між
різними містами-державами
і складалися зі спортивних змагань, таких як
біг і стрибки, а також бойових
заходів, таких як бокс і боротьба,
ігри були часом доброї волі, усі
конфлікти між
містами-державами-учасниками були відкладені до
завершення змагань.
розум місце проведені спортивні змагання бойові
заходи на доброї волі давайте продовжимо
читати сучасні Олімпійські ігри розпочалися
в Афінах 1896 року 14 націй і 241
спортсмен змагалися в 43 змаганнях сьогодні
існує близько 300 заходів і більше  r 205
країн-учасниць включені майже всі
види спорту, включаючи події кватак,
такі як плавання. Ігри
регулюються Міжнародним олімпійським
комітетом і кожні чотири
роки проводяться іншою країною. Олімпіади
не проводилися в 1916, 1940 і 1944 роках
через війну, будь ласка, будь ласка, спортсменам
участь у водних змаганнях регулюється
добре,
давайте перейдемо до нашого читання, оскільки
ігри стали популярнішими. Олімпійський
комітет вніс деякі важливі зміни в
1921 році вони вирішили провести зимову
версію Олімпійських ігор, які
зимові Олімпійські ігри офіційно розпочалися 1924 року
у Франції в 1960 році  У Римі відбулися перші
офіційні Паралімпійські ігри – багатоспортивний
захід, який дозволив спортсменам з
фізичними вадами брати участь у змаганнях. Це було
розпочато як невелика спортивна подія серед
британських ветеранів двох світової війни в 1948 році
в 2010 році Сінгапур прийняв перші Юнацькі
Олімпійські ігри, які дозволили Атласу
між віками  14 і 18 змагатися
до речі ось фото нашого
Паралима  pic team Я дійсно пишаюся ними,
тому на цьому слайді ви повинні
відзначити фізичні вади та ветеранів,
то чому я попросив вас звернути увагу на
ці слова я хочу, щоб ви знайшли
визначення цих слів добре ще
раз ми'  ми відбулися ми маємо спортивні
змагання бойові заходи спортсмени доброї волі
беруть участь у водних змаганнях регламентовані
фізичні недоліки ветерани давайте
поглянемо на перші
спортивні змагання визначення, які включають біг,
стрибки та метання, що це право
, це спортивний захід або спортивні
змагання, тому що є  багато з них,
давайте подивимося на
спортивні змагання другого визначення, в яких
конкуренти б'ються один з одним борються,
хлопці, ви граєте на playstation, тоді ви
точно повинні знати це слово, це
бойові події
Mortal Kombat, до речі, це спорт,
щоб грати у відеоігри
так, тоді  настають спортивні змагання, які
відбуваються у воді, аквапарку, аквапарку, це
водні змагання, вони включають плавання,
до речі, створені для того, щоб
відбутися  ручка ви повинні знайти синонім,
синонім тримається, це минула
форма дієслова hold, тому наступна форма
цікавить, що ускладнює виконання
речей, які виконують інші люди, наприклад
робота, якщо травми це пов'язано з
фізичними вадами так правильні фізичні недоліки
давайте рухатися  далі колишні солдати дії
солдати ветерани це правильно
контроль знайдіть синонім і це
правильно регулятори дружні
почуття співпраці це добра воля правильно
добре, хлопці, давайте продовжуємо, тож ось
події, які ви можете побачити на різних Олімпійських
іграх, давайте переглянемо колонки
тому перша колона стрільба з лука фехтування на 100
метрів і марафон хм, я хотів
би спробувати марафон одного дня, потім друга
колона баскетбол хокей диск і
водне поло Я ніколи не пробував жодного з них,
можливо баскетбол, але давно в школі
велосипедного дзюдо  стрибки у висоту та
важка атлетика Мені дуже подобається
важка атлетика, а потім останній стовпчик
стрибки у воду веслування стрибки в довжину і
тому яке завдання у вас буде чотири
категорії  es і ви повинні розмістити
наступні змагання в правильні
категорії нижче добре, давайте подивимося на першу
категорію
легкоатлетичні змагання спортивні змагання
давайте виберемо всі спортивні змагання, які ви
можете побачити в таблиці, ви готові
дати свою відповідь добре, давайте перевіримо 100
метрів мм
-хм стрибок у довжину стрибок у висоту
приховати Сергій Бубка марафон
і диск право подивіться на наступну
категорію бойові події combat це
про боротьбу бої ок я дивлюсь
у таблицю, щоб знайти всі
бойові події, а ось вони
дзюдо фехтування та боротьба, до речі,
ти пам'ятаєш, як ми говоримо грати, йти або займатися
дзюдо, що було на попередньому уроці так,
ми займаємося дзюдо, добре,
наступна категорія водні змагання хм
, це те, що ми робимо у воді, так що
вони дозволяють мені взяти  подивіться добре, я можу
помітити декілька, чи можете ви написати дайвінг, водне
поло та веслування, а потім найпростіша
категорія,
це називається інші, а інші це
всі ліворуч, так що інші праві,
вони важка атлетика стрільба з лука хокей
їзда на велосипеді та баскетбол
добре, тепер ми готові рухатися далі, якщо
ви добре, щоб бути у формі та бути
здоровим, і щоб мати можливість займатися
різними видами спорту, вам потрібно мати
здорове харчування, так само з англійською, якщо
ви хочете вільно володіти та  якщо ви
хочете мати гарні навички розмовної
англійської мови, вам потрібно мати граматичні закуски,
тож давайте перекусимо граматикою. Я взяв
кілька речень із тексту, який ми прочитали,
перш ніж давайте розглянемо їх ближче,
тож перше речення, з якого почалися сучасні
Олімпійські ігри  Афіни в 1896 році, чому у
нас слово почалося червоним, що це
означає, давайте подивимося на друге
речення, оскільки ігри стали
популярнішими. Олімпійський комітет знову вніс деякі
важливі зміни. Виділено два слова,
стали і зробили, а наступне
речення вони  розпочався як невелика
спортивна подія серед двох ветеранів британської світової війни
в 1948 році, і
знову червоним словом почалося добре, хлопці, ми
говоримо про минулі події, а щоб
говорити про минулі події, ми н  потрібно
використовувати форму минулого часу дієслів, які ми маємо
тут п’ять дієслів begin, стали зроблені і
запущені, так запущено, це звичайне дієслово, щоб
утворити форму минулого часу, вам потрібно додати
закінчення ed started then begin become
made або неправильні дієслова та утворити
це форма минулого часу, вам потрібно використати
таблицю неправильних дієслів, і щоб вивчити її,
знову ж таки, минула форма початку begin
– це минула форма postal і made –
це форма минулого часу make, тому сьогодні
ми поговоримо про минуле просте  коли
ми використовуємо past simple ми використовуємо post simple
для завершених дій у
минулому подивіться на приклад речення
Англія виграла чемпіонат світу в 1966 році добре,
що було занадто давно в 1966 році
я хотів би, щоб Англія грала краще, добре,
друга причина використовувати  минулі прості
повторювані дії в минулому, типи
рутин, які ви робили в минулому, давайте
подивимося на цей приклад. Джон грав у
футбол кожен день,
коли він був дитиною, яке щасливе
дитинство грати у футбол щодня, а
Джон робив це регулярно щодня,
а потім приходить  загальна правда про минуле
загальна правда - це те, що ми всі
знаємо, що це
факт подивіться на цей факт Генрі
восьмий
грав у теніс Я хочу, щоб ви перевірили факти
, щоб ви дізналися, чи
правда ця інформація, чи грав Генрі восьмий у
теніс  ми побачимо наступного разу, і ми
використовуємо past simple, щоб говорити про головні
події в історії, давайте подивимося на
цю коротку історію Джон Джон і Том
чудово провели день, вони грали у футбол, їли
морозиво та відвідали своїх друзів,
що чудово  день, коли вони мали ще раз
розповісти про події в історії, яку ми
використовуємо, ми використовуємо past simple note тут був чудовий
день
зіграли у футбол з'їли морозива
ще раз відвідали своїх друзів,
щоб підсумувати все, що я сказав, past
simple використовується для завершених дій
у минулому повторюється  дії в минулому
загальна правда про минуле та основні
події в історії знову в
минулому добре ось історія Анни,
вона чудово відпочивала в Англії
подивіться на цю історію швидко перегляньте  gh
від початку до кінця
оповідання, щоб ви могли отримати повне уявлення
про текст. Поспішайте добре, де ви,
хлопці, ви десь тут або завжди чи
вже тут добре, то яке завдання
ви маєте виконати, щоб виконати наступний текст,
використовуючи  минулий час дієслів у
дужках іншими словами, треба
розкрити дужки добре,
давайте почнемо читати оповідання.
Англія на два тижні залишитися залишитися
, це звичайне дієслово, тому мені потрібно
закінчення Edie, що означає, що вона пробула в
коледжі в Англії два тижні, добре,
вона гляне вранці, а
вдень мати це неправильне дієслово,
вам потрібна друга форма, і якщо  ви
не знаєте це, зверніться до таблиці
неправильних дієслів, тому вона проводила заняття
вранці, а вдень вона
знову неправильне дієслово робити минулу форму is
займалася деякими видами спорту, як-от плавання або теніс,
які
бувають часто  of people and some English okay
meat — неправильне дієслово, а минула
форма — Matt і learn — це знову
неправильне дієслово, а минула форма —
трохи англійська, усі студенти
її класу be I know was over students
plural forum that should be were  вибачте,
що повертаюся додому, вони всі обіцяють, що це легко
, це звичайне дієслово, яке закінчується Еді,
тому всі вони пообіцяли повернутися наступного
літа, добре попрацюйте, хлопці,
давайте рухатися далі добре, хлопці, чи хотіли б ви
побути деякий час вчителем,
особисто я люблю прикидатися
студент і сядьте серед моїх учнів у
класі, щоб тепер ви могли бути вчителями, у вас
буде кілька речень з
помилками, які ви повинні виправити
помилки, давайте подивимося на перше
речення, яке він не показав моїй бабусі, так
що це найпростіше
неправильно з реченням правильно вона
не бачила мою бабусю, коли приходить вчинок,
друга форма зникає, ви повинні
використовувати першу форму з did okay чи можете ви
зробити
другу поліція спіймала їх піймала я зробив
все  ing correct catched in D
past form no why not catch це
неправильне дієслово right the police caught
them hmm okay maybe the next one I go to
keep yesterday goed again Edie what’s
wrong with you guys that's okay Ні
, це неправильне дієслово right я пішов
до Києва вчора звісно я пішов
пішов все правильно наступний
вона йшла одна я ставлю це на
перше місце помилка викликається нам
не потрібне закінчення ти такий розумний
да вона йшла сама звичайно ми робимо
не потрібно закінчень, коли є мертвий
і останній із Силією і я були найкращими
друзями, що тут не так, я був о, ми
забули Селію, це правильно, це
множина, і це має бути дурнішим, і я
був найкращими друзями,
хлопці, ви дуже розумні, і ви можете
навчіть, можливо, ваші молодші брати чи
сестри
добре, давайте подивимося, чи
можете ви вибрати правильну відповідь, чи можете ви
вибрати правильний варіант, ви побачите
кілька варіантів, і ви повинні
вибрати правильний, давайте подивимося, щоб
речення було правильним Дарр  uk купив
машину Даррен купив автомобіль чи Даррен
купив машину думав деякий час так чи Даррен
купив машину зробив на першому місці
купив на першому форумі і
речення правильне
ок наступне те саме завдання, який
науковець корумпований хто  зробив до
магазину пішов хмм хто пішов до магазину
хто пішов до магазину який із них
був хитрим тобі потрібен цей хто
незалежний він не потрібен зробив так що ви
просто вказали хто замість імені і
ви отримали  питання найпростіше,
хто пішов до магазину наступне, чому
вона пішла додому рано
чому вона пішла додому рано чому вона
пішла додому рано, гм, мені потрібно зробити, тому я
повинен подумати про речення з дією
є два речення з не
в останньому є двигун
, це не минула форма, тож
правильний: чому вона пішла додому рано
, це правильно, а наступний, де
Джулія та Метт їли вечерю, де
Джулія та Метт їли вечерю, де були
Джулія та Метт  ate dinner hmm
я думаю, що правильний є ri
правильний є другий,
де Джулія та Метт обідали, давайте
продовжуємо добре, хлопці, ми підходимо до
кінця уроку, і я маю
для вас вікторину наступного разу, будьте готові зі
своїми відповідями, ви будете  дізнайтеся правильні
відповіді на початку наступного
уроку, давайте переглянемо запитання, які
ви маєте, ви повинні перевірити свої
знання про легку атлетику, тому перше
запитання — це світовий рекорд із 100 картинок
, а три вихідні варіанти — що таке
рекорд, до речі  хто був спортсменом,
який це зробив, хм, другий на більшості
відкритих атлетичних доріжок один круг –
це лабораторне коло на стадіоні, тож
і скільки метрів 200 400 800
шукайте правильну відповідь виконані спортивні змагання,
які включають стрибки та кидки
холодна заповнена траса водна, безумовно, не
водна, добре, наступний eval,
який складається з легкоатлетичних
змагань, викликається, якщо десять і латинське
слово для повороту: ви точно
знаєте відповідь Олімпійські ігри 2004 року  mes були
проведені в Beijing Co або в Афінах, хм,
якщо ви не знаєте, що можете зробити це,
і останній об’єкт, який
передається від Rana для запуску в естафеті
, називається естафетою, це коли ви
біжите до свого  товариш по команді, ти даєш
щось йому чи їй, а потім він
продовжує бігти, це естафета,
а що ти
передаєш джойстиком, тож до зустрічі наступного разу Сподіваюся,
вам сподобався цей урок, і будьте готові
з відповідями, щоб перевірити їх наступного
разу  до зустрічі, хлопці
[музика].